hello and thank you everyone for being
here I'm sorry but this is gonna be
about testing the front end so I might I
know that you might have expected
something interesting right after lunch
but if you happen to stay with me well I
want to explain you I want to show you
how testing the front end
shouldn't be that hard and it actually
isn't that hard as long as you have the
right mindset you follow the right
strategy and you use the appropriate
tools I'm Nadia from Kavita
I'm a senior whatever that means
software engineer at Ola loose which is
a green energy provider where we connect
people to the green energy I'm also one
of the maintainer of testing library and
open source project based on testing
modern web applications and also one of
the co-organizers of the view Jes meetup
in my hometown in in Barcelona so what
this is where this is this talk coming
from today's fish talk team you might
have you might remember that he said
that building web applications is hard
right and and that's true because at
some point we as a front-end industry if
that even exists we decided that we had
powerful tools so we could ask for
responsibilities to our back-end
counterpart right so our applications
grow grew in complexity but we didn't
ask for the right tools or the right
approach to handle that responsibility
and one of those responsibilities is
testing so if our biggest ins are way
more complex than expected well we
should be testing them right so I
noticed that I knew I was doing other
stuff so I knew that I need to get into
testing first thing I did
obviously well started with the testing
pyramid like like everyone I guess you
know this idea of writing a lot of unit
tests so I'm interesting test and
finally some end-to-end testing but with
that was created like 10 years ago
so to be honest it failed me or I failed
the pyramid probably it didn't work and
instead of thinking that
testing is not for me or that ya know
testing is hot already it was as myself
or wonder what were the ideas supporting
the pyramid why was the pyramid there at
the end I came up with a realization
that they were asking us to write tests
that's quite obvious right but also we
should make them fast to run and cheap
to maintain tests should be focused on
the value they provide and we need to
run them often so we need will have a
feedback on how our application is
behaving in short where we should be
creating shorter and faster feedback
loops for for our app so this talk was
called pragmatic for intestine so I want
to keep things pragmatic I'll show you
an example of what I try to do you want
to test my my applications so I'm gonna
ask who's using view
usually on a I can see you so yeah raise
your hand so I can see you
yeah a lot of fans know every new excuse
to raise your hand just in case yeah
great so I'm gonna show you an example a
simple component if you ever use view
it's gonna be so simple if you don't
it's gonna be so simple to because it's
just a counter you know this is view
looks great you just have a text you
have a button you can click the button
you call the increment method you just
increment the state value that count
variable
no tricks right quite simple since you
are using view what we'll do then just
have a huge ecosystem of tools with
focus on testing the D component using
the official testing library right so we
would use view test utils we would you
know mount if you're if you are into
react this is quite similar to enzyme if
you are into angular kind of sorry so
you want that counter component and you
get a wrapper in return and then with
that rubber you could do things such as
using the fine method for instance to
get an element based on its HTML class
or you can also then after you add the
paragraph use the text method to make
sure that you click zero times is is
they're after that well wrapper dot VM
exposes you with the whole component
instance so you can call its increment
method twice because we can and after
that you would just assert that you
click two times is there in the script
right
it looks quite simple this is how you
test a component so thank you for coming
to my TED talk it was almost done so you
could have not stopped me but just get
let's say that we have this component
right and then some random senior
software engineer on a pull request just
says that you know this increment method
its increment is like a long word right
and it's prone to errors why don't you
just replace it with add right
it's yeah make sense I mean he's senior
software engineer so yeah your proof is
changes you merge them then you manually
test your component and yeah everything
keeps working
finally you run your test suit yep that
test is failing it's failing because the
end of increment no longer exists it
makes sense this is quite important from
my point of view because this is what
it's called a false positive error where
our test is broken but our component is
not and this undermines our confidence
in testing this is you know this feeling
where tests just fail at random times
and you don't know why and you cannot
explain why and we all know that selling
the whole testing idea even among our
peers and not to talk about business
people is quite difficult so we want to
avoid that scenario right so the
question here is what went wrong what
happened how did we end up here the
answer to our question is that our test
became what is called a different
consumer and I know what you might be
thinking a different what yeah ok
so to answer this question we need to
take a step back and first realize or
answer what is a test so we test in
general it's simply a set of inputs
passed in to a function that will get
another set of outputs in return and
then we need to match our expectations I
those outputs right this is what the
best looks like in the front end well
the whole thing is still holds true
right
we don't use function we do use
functions but you usually call them
components right in the end component
just boil down to function so it is a
whole same thing the same mental model
still applies the question here is what
are our inputs and our outputs on on our
front-end applications or put it in
another way
who's emitting those inputs and who's
receiving those outputs this question
can be answered once we realize that our
code has two users first of them well
the end user obviously the person of the
people who are who are we we are
building the application for of we're
gonna get value from it but also the
developer the developer is also using a
worker right another team mate might
import our component or even yourself so
you are your own code
consumer yep so those are the users who
are gonna provide us with inputs and who
are gonna expect some outputs so without
inputs what are the inputs that we might
get from a development point of view
well in a UI component we might get
props or attributes or whatever and also
data streams
I know subscriptions and so on and from
a end-user point of view well the inputs
are going to be interactions
you know clicking typing scrolling
although all those kind of actions and
what about the outputs while the outputs
from a development side we've called
them side effects but with that I mean
HTTP requests cookies local storage a
console logs for instance all those kind
of things that go beyond the component
boundaries and from a user end-user
perspective while the output is just Dom
elements right this is why we use viewer
we are felt and so on just to render
things on a screen
so this is quite abuse once you realize
about that but you know 99% of times
that's everything you want to focus on
when testing UI components and it's
quite simple once you have this on
screen but took me a while to realize
about yeah longer than I'm willing to
admit on public so in short we get props
data streams and user interactions and
we generate all we need to expect side
effects and Dom nodes why do you tell
you all of this stuff well because in
our tests the tests that we wrote before
we were called something like v MDOT
increment or find using an HTML class
and my question here is is that this
behaving like the end user is it
behaving like a developer well the
answer is obviously no and so the the
the consequence of that is that your or
we earned ourselves a third user right
we now have the end user we have the
developer and now we have the test so
since we have a third user we need to
fulfill its requirements so now we are
tied to that third user and that's
something that you want to avoid so when
I said that the test became a different
consumer what I meant is that now we
need to take that test into account when
we're factoring when just using our
component so we're here down the road
and the question is how can I stay away
from those implementation details right
how can I avoid creating this dreaded
third user the answer is that we need to
use the appropriate tools and this is
why I'm here interesting you to the dom
testing library ecosystem which is just
simple and complete testing switch
utilities just to test several
everything that relies on the Dom in the
Dom so it is not the test Runner or
framework just builds on top of other
tools and we have several ports and it's
guiding principle of the
the main idea is that the more your
terms assemble the way your sufferer is
used the more confidence they can give
you this is the guiding principle of the
whole life livery
written or yeah written by Kent C Dodds
it's creator and the information of that
sentence is that we need to reduce the
gap between the test and the user so we
cannot create that third user in the
middle on top of them testing library we
have several a rubbers do you make it
simple to use it with your favorite
framework and development environments
such as cypress for instance so if you
want to avoid implementation details you
need to use tools that help you out so
let let me show you an example how I
would test that counter component using
vo test library in this case notice how
here would just render the counter not
mounting just rendering it on a deep for
instance and this returns me a
collection of utilities in this case I
would use get by text as you would
expect get by to expose tries to get
something by its text so what I would do
what we would be doing here is to assert
initial state by querying our component
using a rebel expression or a string
doesn't matter and it will get me in
return the Dom node with the Associated
text right in this case I just want to
make sure that the test exists so as
well I just need to expect that it
returns something after that if you
remember the test we were incrementing
the count value right so but here we
need to as we said we need to stay
closer to our user so what we would be
doing here is to click on the button I
mean we can go to our users home and
just click using its mouse but it
doesn't really scale so we kind of
compromise here right what we've done is
what we get the button obviously notice
how get by text returns me the dumb note
and this is actually a button this is an
HTML button element right so what we do
here is we click on it as close as a
user would so we fire the click
and on top of the bottom right which is
roughly the same thing that you would do
with their mouse after that we just
expect that you click two times would be
on a screen
notice how the test looks quite similar
to the other one but here we are
querying our component as a user would
by reading its text and also we are
acting upon our component as close as
possible as a user would and that's an
additional benefit to that test if you
notice there are only two lines there
which are related to view one is
obviously well the import statement
that's quite clear and the other one is
the render function right because we are
passing in a view component now let's
imagine that our component was written
in react for instance this is how the
test would look like we would be
importing testing library to react
obviously and then we would render it
using JSX because react and the rest of
the test well it will look the same
because turns out our users don't really
care about our framework they just want
to make sure they can click and that the
count viral increments properly so in
the end we wrote a test that it's kind
of framework agnostic which from my
point of view it's beneficial and also
stays closer to our users so we avoid
creating this third user and we avoid
relying on implementation details so
dumb testing library offers although
several matches I'm not gonna go through
them you have an extensive documentation
online but I wanted to show you another
one which you know kind of ready with
other talks from today which is the get
by level text when passing in a level of
string it gets you the Associated input
in return so it's not only comfortable
when testing but also kind of asserts
certain level of accessibility in our
application which is great so wrapping
it up and just to finish my explanation
here
I want you to write test I think it
makes sense but so I not to focus on
quantity try not to focus on type just
make sure that this cut you out just
make sure they provide value in the end
we want test to sleep better at night
input and output 1 testing UI components
it might be counterintuitive at the
beginning but components are just
functions so we need to provide them
with inputs and expect the appropriate
output and finally try to use tools that
resemble the way your server is used so
you avoid relying on implementation
details and you avoid a dreaded for user
not gonna become a nightmare at some
point you want to start now you have
this testing library calm which is the
home page of the project it's an open
source project so feel free to check it
out and we are open to contributions
obviously and just remember that the
important part of this is not the tools
it's about having the right mindset and
following same strategy just to make
sure that your tests are helping you out
and you can probably introduce the idea
to your team that's everything I wanted
to tell you about thank you for having
me here it's been an honor and feel free
to stop me if you have any question
around the hall
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]